und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend das pandemiegeschehen ist
weiter dynamisch vielleicht sind die
Verfallsdaten von politischen
Entscheidungen ein brauchbarer Maßstab
dafür am 10 August war beschlossen
worden dass es keine kostenlosen Tests
mehr geben soll damals konnte man auf so
eine Idee kommen der offizielle Grund
war Fairness die Gemeinschaft soll nicht
für persönliche Entscheidungen der um
impf-unwilligen Zahlen das wirkt heute
unter den aktuellen Zahlen kleinkariert
der heimliche Grund damals war man
wollte die unwilligen per Geldbeutel zur
Impfung treiben und das hat nicht
funktioniert immer mehr fordern jetzt
damit aufzuhören und die Tests wieder zu
zahlen den Bürgern bietet sich insgesamt
ein Bild von durcheinander mancherorts
wird allerdings durchaus entschieden
gehandelt Peter Kunst berichtet
unser Nachbarland Österreich zieht den
Zaun zwischen geimpften und ungeimpften
hoch ab morgen 2G in Restaurants Hotels
beim Friseur Österreich wo das Virus zu
Anfang noch toben durfte lebt nun in der
Corona zwei Klassengesellschaft
wir kennen nur alle hoffen
finanziell und gesundheitlich dass diese
Regelung jetzt wirkt so weit wie Wien
geht Hamburg noch nicht aber 2G auch
hier auf der vollen Reeperbahn 2G als
Option für die sich Gastronomie
theatermuseen oder Kirchen in der
Hansestadt entscheiden dürfen auf dem
Hamburger Dom der Herbstkirmes müssen
ungeimpfte auf jeden Fall draußen
bleiben mehr Zwang im Alltag ist mit
bald auslaufender epidemischer Notlage
rechtlich kaum drin
es gibt noch einzelne Bereiche wo man
sagen kann da macht man auch kein 3G
mehr da machen wir nur noch zwei g aber
ich sag mal ganz große sehr wirksame
zwar aber natürlich sehr sehr
freiheitseinschränkende Eingriffe werden
auf dieser Basis dann natürlich nicht
mehr möglich sein wir werden jetzt sehen
wie wir so durch den Winter kommen der
zweite Virus Winter trifft auf ein
Gesundheitssystem am Anschlag nach 19
Monaten Corona laufen die
Intensivstationen schon wieder voll fast
nur mit ungeimpften gleichzeitig müssen
Betten stillgelegt werden weil
überlastete Pflegekräfte geschmissen
haben wir sind vorbereitet wir haben
auch ein System wo wir innerhalb von
Deutschland sind weniger belastete
Gebiete verlegen können und diese ganzen
Maßnahmen werden dazu führen dass wir
das schon ich sag mal einfach salopp
wuppen werden diesen Herbst aber die
Nachbarländer blicken ja ganz verwundert
auf Deutschland den Musterschüler
Europas und fragen sich was ist da los
wieso schaffen wir es nicht die
Impfungen so durchzubringen wie wir das
in anderen Ländern Stichwort Spanien
tatsächlich sehen und das zeigt eine
enorme Schwäche und das ist ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches Problem eine
Gesellschaft die nicht mehr schafft alle
mitzunehmen mit einer Epidemie der
ungeimpften und impfunwilligen so wie in
Sachsen wo die Infektionszahlen durch
die Decke gehen
wir brauchen die Tests wieder wir
brauchen 3G am Arbeitsplatz so wie das
auch unsere österreichischen Nachbarn
machen man braucht 2G solange es nicht
anders ermöglich ist und wir brauchen
vor allen Dingen ein gemeinsames Agieren
von Bund und Länder hatte man es nicht
gemeinsam versucht eineinhalb Jahre lang
neues Spiel neue Ernst neuer Bundestag
wo bleibt beim koalitionspoker die
pandemiebekämpfung ein parallel zu
Verschwiegenheit von Verhandlungen die
im Hintergrund stattfinden findet ein
intensiver Prozess der Gesetzgebung
statt um Schutzmaßnahmen für den Winter
im Sinne eines sicheren Winters auf den
Weg zu bringen und dafür zu sorgen dass
wir erstens Maßnahmen die gerade
zurückgenommen wurden wie kostenlose
Tests wieder einführen zu Verfügung
stellen und ungeimpfte abholen wo sie
das noch zulassen so wie hier mit
mobilen impfteams vor Moscheen in
Braunschweig wer aber bekommt wenn es
eng wird den beatmungsplatz jemand der
aus medizinischen Gründen nicht werden
durfte oder jemand der nicht geimpft
werden wollte da spreche als
medizinetikerin und da ist klar dass wir
wenn es um lebenserhaltende Maßnahmen
geht in der Medizin kein Schuld oder
Verursacherprinzip haben sondern ist
nach Fürsorge
gleichbehandlungs- und
solidaritätsprinzipien geht man muss
sich aber auch einfach klar machen dass
ein sehr sehr großer Teil der
Bevölkerung inzwischen geimpft ist und
sich natürlich auch ein wenig fragt
warum kann das nicht endlich alles
vorbei sein viele Fragen nur eins ist
sicher für ungeimpfte wird der Winter
viel schwerer werden als für die
Mehrheit der Deutschen
die Freie und Hansestadt Hamburg hat ein
Arzt zum Ersten Bürgermeister guten
Abend Herr tschinger guten Abend Herr
Kleber Herr drmann wird die Sache nicht
einfach so laufen lassen können was
braucht es jetzt wir haben in Hamburg
schon im August die 2g-regelung
eingeführt weil der sicherste Schutz bei
infektionsgefährdeten Versammlung ist
dass alle geimpft oder genesen sind und
das ist sehr wirksam das muss jetzt in
ganz Deutschland auch umgesetzt werden
das ist natürlich indirekt die
Einführung eines speziellen lockdowns
nur für ungeimpfte keine Diskotheken
keine knacken kein Theater und so weiter
verunglimpfte es ist zugleich ein Anreiz
die Impfung anzunehmen denn sie steht
allen zur Verfügung und wir können diese
Pandemie nicht immer aus der Sicht der
ungeimpften beurteilen die große Zahl
der schon geimpften Personen in Hamburg
sind über 86 Prozent der Erwachsenen
bereits geimpft die haben auch Rechte
und wir können jetzt nicht aufgrund von
wenigen diese Pandemie immer noch wieder
verschlimmern vor allem die Lage in den
Intensivstationen schlechter werden
lassen wir müssen jetzt wirklich
konsequent sein das heißt Impfungen auf
vielen verschiedenen Wegen anbieten mit
zwei g-regelungen Sicherheit herstellen
aber eben auch einen Anreiz zusätzlich
geben und sind sie auch dafür die
kostenlosen Tests wieder einzuführen
denn selbst wenn man geimpft ist ist es
ja noch keine Garantie dass man das
Virus nicht überträgt das heißt eine
Impfung vorm Besuch des Altenheims oder
auch der ganz normalen Verwandten oder
einer Party wer ein Test obendrauf schon
sinnvoll ja in solchen Einrichtungen wie
zum Beispiel Seniorenheim werden
zusätzliche Tests gemacht die werden ja
auch dann bezahlt von Arbeitgeber für
die Beschäftigten sie werden angeboten
von den Einrichtungen für Besucher das
gibt es weiterhin aber man darf jetzt
nicht auf Nebenfragen ausweichen der
Kern der Sache ist dass wir in vielen
Bundesländern eine zu niedrige Impfquote
haben und dort eskaliert jetzt auch die
Situation warum ist diese Impfquote
eigentlich so niedrig denn die Zahl der
aktiven ich will mich niemals impfen
lassen Verweigerer ist gar nicht so hoch
hat man zu früh den Fuß vom Gaspedal
genommen mit den großen Impfzentren mit
den Aktionen wurde zu wenig geworben ja
wenn 20 30 40 Prozent der Bevölkerung
nicht geimpft sind sind das riesen
zahlen und das sind das alles ja das
sind Personen die noch nicht erreicht
worden sind deswegen muss die Botschaft
klar sein es sind wirklich alle jetzt
dringend zur Impfung aufgefordert wir
haben in Hamburg unterschiedlichste Wege
wir gehen in Kirchengemeinden den
Sportvereine in alle Stadtteile in
Einkaufszentren bieten aktiv die Impfung
überall an das hat uns auf einen sehr
guten Platz im Länderranking der
Impfquote geführt wir sind wie ich sagte
mit über 86 Prozent der Erwachsenen
jetzt haben wir einen guten Schutz aber
es braucht eigentlich alle und deswegen
jetzt diese zwei g-regelung die wir seit
August
umgesetzt haben die sich auch bewährt
hat und das kann ich wirklich nur allen
Ländern empfehlen man wundert sich ja
schon als Bürger das ist möglich war
jetzt im Oktober noch mal ein massiveres
Vorgehen bei den impfangeboten zu machen
man hätte doch wohl erwartet dass man
alles Menschen mögliche bereits im
August und September und im Oktober
getan hat offenbar waren da Reserven
ungenutzt liegengeblieben also ich kann
ja nur für Hamburg sprechen wir haben
diese aktive Impfkampagne seit zur
Verfügungstellung des Impfstoffs gemacht
ich gehe davon aus dass alle Länder sich
hier bemüht haben aber ich sage noch
einmal wir müssen unterschiedlichste
Wege gehen um die noch nicht geimpften
zu erreichen die Wege müssen so
unterschiedlich sein wie die Menschen
unterschiedlich sind die bisher noch
skeptisch sind an der ein wichtiger
Anreiz ist wirklich die Erkenntnis zu
sehen dass es ohne diese Impfung nicht
geht und das ist auch für die
ungeimpften schwer wird jetzt in den
nächsten Monaten am öffentlichen Leben
teilzunehmen nun gibt es eine wirklich
technische gesetzgeberische kleine kinke
in den ganzen Planungen für die nächsten
Wochen am 25 November läuft diese
pandemieerklärung aus das bedeutet ab
dem Tag dürfen dann die Länder auch
manche der Dinge die sie jetzt
geschlossen haben dann nicht mehr machen
da muss jetzt irgendwas passieren um das
zu verlängern fühlt sich eigentlich die
Ampel also auch ihre Partei dafür schon
mitverantwortlich ja und das ist so und
uns ist zugesichert worden dass die
Maßnahmen die die Länder brauchen auch
in Zukunft sichergestellt sind ich bin
der Auffassung gewesen man hätte diese
Pandemie Erklärung verlängern sollen bis
mindestens Ende des Jahres aber nun muss
es einen anderen Weg geben damit nicht
der große Lockdown für alle wieder
eintritt aber dass die Maßnahmen die wir
brauchen insbesondere ungeimpfte jetzt
zu schützen vor Infektionen die sie ins
Krankenhaus in schwere Erkrankungen
bringen kann dass wir diese Maßnahmen
auch rechtlich alle absichern sie hatten
gerade von ihrem medizinerkollegen
Janssen in unserem Stück gehört wie er
sagte dass das Bild dass die deutsche
Gesellschaft abgibt für das Ausland und
auch für ihn ein Bild der Schwäche sei
der Gesellschaft wie sie das Thema jetzt
in den letzten Wochen angepackt hat
teilen Sie das Urteil es gibt jedenfalls
ein großes Unverständnis bei denjenigen
die auf Intensivstationen arbeiten das
ist immer noch Zweifel gibt das geimpft
werden muss und es geht ein Stück weit
auf dem Rücken der Beschäftigten dann
wenn zu viele Menschen sagen ich will
mich nicht impfen lassen ich will aber
normal leben und dieses Virus ignorieren
und erwartet dann aber natürlich auch
eine Behandlung wenn ich schwer erkranke
das ist sehr erschöpfend für die
Beschäftigten auf den Intensivstationen
und auch dies sollte ein Argument sein
an die Pflegekräfte zu denken und die
Impfung anzunehmen danke Herr Center und
einen schönen Abend sehr gerne
und hier geht es weiter mit Nachrichten
von Gundula Gauss
den Messerangriff gestern in einem ICE
bewerten die Ermittler nicht als
Terrorakt sondern führen ihn auf
psychische Probleme des Täters zurück
der 27-Jährige Syrer habe
Wahnvorstellungen gehabt als er in einem
ICE kurz hinter Regensburg wahllos auf
Mitreisende einstach und dabei vier
Männer verletzte so ein Gutachter auf
den sich die Kripo bei der
Pressekonferenz heute bezog auf Antrag
der Staatsanwaltschaft kommt der Mann
zunächst in eine psychiatrische Klinik
ermittelt wird weiter wegen versuchten
Mordes
in iraks-hauptstadt Bagdad hat
Regierungschef al cassimi einen
Drohnenangriff unbeschadet überstanden
laut Militär attackierte eine mit
Sprengstoff beladene Drohne den
Regierungssitz sechs personenschütze
wurden verletzt der Irak ist seit der
Parlamentswahl im Oktober in einer
politischen Krise nach dem Anschlag rief
alcacini die Bevölkerung zu Ruhe und
Zurückhaltung auf am Wochenende waren
bei Protesten rund 100 Menschen verletzt
worden
Äthiopiens Ministerpräsident Abi Achmed
hat zum Widerstand gegen die Truppen der
volksbefreiungsfront der abtrünnigen
Region t-grei aufgerufen die Bevölkerung
müsse Opfer bringen um das Land zu
retten hunderttausende folgten Abis
Aufruf zu Protestmärschen um der Armee
ihre Unterstützung zu demonstrieren seit
2018 entmachtete Armee die
volksbefreiungsfront die einst die Macht
integrai hatte vor einem Jahr begann er
zudem eine Militäroffensive gegen die
einstigen Machthaber derzeit werden die
Kämpfe immer härter
der scheidende Ratsvorsitzende der
Evangelischen Kirche in Deutschland
Bedford Strom hat sich unzufrieden mit
der Aufarbeitung des sexuellen
Missbrauchs in seiner Kirche geäußert
auf der Tagesordnung der von heute an
digital tagenden Synode stehen auch der
Reformstau und der Mitgliederschwund der
evangelischen Kirche sowie die Nachfolge
von bedford-strom der nach sieben Jahren
im Amt nicht erneut kandidiert
die Bundesregierung beziffert die
Schäden der Flutkatastrophe im Juli auf
29,2 Milliarden Euro das geht aus einem
Antrag auf EU-Finanzhilfen hervor und
ist ein Rekordwert der die Schadensummen
der Flutkatastrophen 2002 und 2013 um
ein Vielfaches übersteigt mehr als die
Hälfte davon entfällt jetzt auf
Rheinland-Pfalz vor allem auf das Ahrtal
rund 40 Prozent kamen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen zusammen etwa 10% in
Sachsen und Bayern
Klimaschutz kann gefährlich werden für
die Politik in Regionen den nicht so
weiter gewirtschaftet werden darf wie
bisher ganz vorne dran sind da die
kohle-regionen das was im 20 Jahrhundert
erreichtum war klingt gilt plötzlich als
Gefahr für die Menschheit zum Beispiel
in der Lausitz Mensch Strukturwandel in
solchen Regionen unvermeidlich ist muss
man die Menschen mitnehmen das war immer
das Motto der Politik das ist ein
schöner Spruch aber schwer umzusetzen es
verlangt nämlich was viele Menschen in
der Lausitz zum Beispiel schon lange
nicht mehr haben nämlich Vertrauen in
die Versprechen der Politik die
Bereitschaft der Wähler das verheil dann
bei Protestparteien zu suchen ist groß
dagegen gab es einen abgestimmten
Fahrplan zum Kohleausstieg
der nur mit knirschenden Zähnen von
vielen akzeptiert worden ist und jetzt
soll der offenbar auch noch beschleunigt
werden Nicola Albrecht berichtet da
braut sich was zusammen
tief im Osten in Brandenburg und Sachsen
liegt sie die Lausitz am Rande der
Republik und jetzt plötzlich im Fokus
der Politik und auf ihnen lastet der
Druck den Menschen sie sollen Tempo
machen raus aus dem einstigen Gold der
Region der Kohle und zwar 2030 acht
Jahre früher als vereinbart denn so will
es die zukünftige Ampelkoalition die
Kohle ist nicht mehr in Zukunft das
wissen wir aber wir kämpfen dafür dass
wir hier nicht einfach untergebuttert
werden wir fühlen uns eben zu wenig
gehört wir fühlen uns zu wenig
mitgenommen in diesem Prozess hier kann
er jetzt nicht alles Aussterben was
macht dann meine Familie hier erst die
Jobs dann der Ausstieg so lautete das
Wahlversprechen der Politik daran glaubt
in der Lausitz aktuell kaum jemand im
Rennen um die Vorreiterrolle in der
Energiewende müssten sie hier Gestalter
und nicht Bauernopfer werden doch das
kostet eben Zeit mein Glas katzmarek
die Zahl 2030 zu nennen ist für mich ein
absolutes Unding was wir brauchen ist
Planungssicherheit und da rede ich nicht
nur von der Region sondern ich spreche
auch über Netzausbau
Speichertechnologien und den Einsatz
neuer regenerativer
energieerzeugungsformen und da sehe ich
nicht dass wir das 20 30 schaffen das
2038 schon sportliches Ziel das war mal
eure Wähler der 29-Jährige Mechatroniker
aus Cottbus rappt sich seinen Frust von
der Seele
Perspektive gebt uns
industrie-arbeitsplätze während die
verantwortlichen Politiker in
Brandenburg gerade abtauchen
Ministerpräsident Woitke will zum Thema
kein Interview geben er schickt die
Chefin der Staatskanzlei vor der
vorgezogene Kohleausstieg in ihren Augen
machbar sie hält darin fest dass Jobs
und alternative Energiegewinnung
gewährleistet sein müssten muss
allerdings zugeben dass es dafür keine
Garantie gebe die Lausitz hat aus meiner
Sicht jetzt großartige Chancen
Möglichkeiten die sich hier bieten mit
dem Transformationsprozess zu nutzen wir
sind ja auf einem guten Weg es ist ein
bahnwerk das in Cottbus entsteht wo
Kohlekumpel zukünftig arbeiten könnten
es sind Behörden die sich ansiedeln
sollen es ist der Tourismus der Jobs und
Menschen in die Region bringen soll
alles schön und gut meint Lars kazmarek
aber eben nicht genug wenn Politik
verspricht den Infrastrukturprojekte zu
investieren und mir gesagt wird von der
Landesregierung wir brauchen für das
Gleis diese 50 Kilometer die zwischen
Cottbus und Lübbenau fehlen aber noch
mindestens 9 oder 10 Jahre dann frage
ich mich ernsthaft will man
Strukturwandel wirklich betreiben oder
sind es wie so oft nur heiße und lose
Worte und so haben sich an diesem
Wochenende zehn Lausitzer Bürgermeister
zusammengetan gemeinsam läuten sie
symbolisch eine Glocke die Botschaft die
Politik solle den Menschen hier zuhören
bevor ihr Vertrauen weiter schwindet
sonst schwinden die Bürgermeister
Deutschland hat seine weiße Weste
verloren auf der Weltkarte der Reporter
ohne Grenzen gehört Deutschland nicht
mehr wie selbstverständlich bisher zu
den wenigen Ländern in denen es richtig
gut um die Pressefreiheit steht nur noch
zufriedenstellend weltweit Rang 13 darf
ein Land wie Deutschland nicht
zufriedenstellen der Rückschritt liegt
an zunehmend aggressiver Stimmung in
Teilen der Gesellschaft die mit der
Politik des Landes und der
Berichterstattung nicht einverstanden
sind die kann es die darf es die muss es
geben in einer Demokratie Drohungen oder
Gewalt gegen Journalistinnen und
Journalisten bedrohen allerdings
funktionierende Demokratie Andreas Weise
berichtet
Liebertwolkwitz bei Leipzig Anfang
September Protest gegen ein
Wahlkampfauftritt des sächsischen
Ministerpräsidenten und einer
bundestagskandidatin
[Musik]
ein Journalist der die Proteste
beobachtet wird beschimpft und
schließlich attackiert
dass da ein massives Polizeiaufgebot ist
scheint nicht weiter zu stören
wir sprechen mit Henrik Merker dem
Journalisten dem das passiert ist er hat
viel Erfahrung mit Demos beobachtet dass
seit einiger Zeit immer mehr Wut gegen
die berichterstattenden sichtbar wird es
hat zumindest mit Beginn dieser
querdenkerdemonstration massiv
zugenommen dass auch Leute die man
eigentlich rein vom äußeren im
bürgerlichen Spektrum verorten würde
dass die bei sowas jetzt eben auch sehr
aktiv mitmischen doch nicht nur
fernsehradio oder online-reporterinnen
und Reporter erfahren deutlichen
Gegenwind Hagen Eichler ist Politiker
responent der Mitteldeutschen Zeitung
die Reaktionen auf seine Artikel sind
deutlich mehr und heftiger geworden
alles was an Möglichkeiten da ist wird
genutzt also Anrufe E-Mails bei Twitter
natürlich
gibt es Leute die sich melden und
einfach bei bestimmten Themen immer
wieder anspringen das ist jetzt zur Zeit
ganz stark das Thema Impfen da gibt es
Leute die eben sehr lange E-Mails
schreiben sehr ausführlich aus
irgendwelchen Studien zitieren versuchen
einen zu überzeugen also mit wirklich
viel Mühe und Zeitaufwand einem
Schreiben es gibt aber auch andere die
einfach nur kurz schreiben drei kurze
Beleidigungen und dann war es das für
die hier an der Hochschule Magdeburg
Stendal werden JournalistInnen
Journalisten ausgebildet sie wissen es
gibt heutzutage nicht mehr so hohe
Hürden wenn man ein breites Publikum
erreichen möchte ich denke es hat sich
in dem Sinne geändert dass halt die
Technologie sich jetzt auch
weiterentwickelt hat und dadurch nicht
nur Journalisten jetzt eine Plattform
haben wo sie auf Film und Video gesehen
werden und Ihre Nachricht an die Welt
verbreiten können sondern auch jeder
andere der zu Hause sitzt er kann
sozusagen ein den Journalisten spielen
was macht also schon immer und
vielleicht jetzt noch viel mehr
Journalismus aus
Journalismus lebt gerade heute auch vom
zweiten Gedanken weil die schnelle
Nachricht die schnelle Information ist
überall zugänglich Twitter Facebook und
Co wenn ich aber mir die Zeit nehme
etwas noch mal nachzuprüfen zu
verifizieren zur falsifizieren dann kann
ich als Journalistin da einen guten
nächsten Beitrag zu leisten doch gerade
das scheint viele Gegner der sogenannten
etablierten Medien gar nicht zu
interessieren
also es gibt insgesamt eine
Unzufriedenheit was ja erstmal nicht
schlimm ist man versteht nur nicht dass
es unsere Aufgabe als Journalistin
Journalisten ist diese Unzufriedenheit
auch zu transportieren darüber zu
berichten sondern wir werden irgendwo in
einen Topf geworfen als Systempresse ja
dann haben sie ja recht wir gehören zum
demokratischen System und Demokratie
braucht unabhängige Berichterstattung
und wir kommen zum Sport in der
Fußball-Bundesliga gab es vor der
Länderspielpause an diesem Sonntag drei
Partien der Tabellen letzte Greuther
Fürth verlor gegen Eintracht Frankfurt
eins zu zwei der 1 fC Köln und Union
Berlin trennten sich zwei zu zwei und
ebenfalls unentschieden eins zu eins
trennten sich Hertha BSC und der
Tabellen sechste Bayer Leverkusen
Tennis Geschichte hat der serbische
Topstar Novak Djokovic geschrieben mit
seinem Sieg beim Masters Turnier in
Paris gegen Titelverteidiger Daniel
Medvedev drehte er einen Satz Rückstand
gewann und hat mit diesem 37 Turniersieg
bei einem Masters die meisten Erfolge in
dieser Klasse ein Rekord den bislang
Erzrivale Rafael Nadal hielt
in der Formel 1 hat Max Verstappen den
Großen Preis von Mexiko gewonnen und
nimmt mit seinem 9 Saisonsieg kurz auf
seinen ersten WM-Titeln der Niederländer
im Red Bull setzte sich vor
Rekordweltmeister Louis Hamilton im
Mercedes durch 3 wurde der Mexikaner
Sergio Perez im zweiten Red Bull
beide Schwimm-EM im russischen Kasan hat
Florian Wellbrock sein zweites Gold nur
knapp verpasst und Silber über 800 Meter
Freistil geholt im Ziel trennten den
Magdeburger 5 Hundertstel Sekunden vom
Italiener Gregorio paltrinieri bronze
ging ans Sven schwarz aus Hannover eine
weitere Medaille gab es für wellbrocks
Magdeburger Teamkollegin Isabel Gose
Bronze über 200 Meter Freistil
die mondäne Metropole am Genfer See so
ziemlich der unwahrscheinlichste Ort
unter der Sonne für einen Volksaufstand
gegen einen Motor der Weltwirtschaft
Genferinnen und Genfer sind zu
beharrlichen Kämpfern geworden gegen die
Lawine von Werbung die nicht nur
Weltstädte wie New York mit ihren
Botschaften überschwemmt man kann ja im
öffentlichen Raum kaum noch eine Minute
verbringen ohne grell angebrüllt zu
werden und es wird immer mehr in den
letzten 25 Jahren sind die Werbeausgaben
alleine in Deutschland von zwölf auf gut
34 Milliarden Euro im Jahr gestiegen Eva
Schiller berichtet dem Volk von Genf
reicht das jetzt vielleicht ist das auch
ein Modell Veranlassung
[Musik]
den öffentlichen Raum zurückerobern aus
den Fängen des Kommerzes befreien was
Genf plant hat für Manuel Mischler schon
begonnen eine werbefreie Stadt das
klingt nach Utopie und doch könnte ihr
Wunsch Wirklichkeit werden
[Musik]
es gibt so mehr Platz für das urbane
Milieu zum Beispiel gibt es in den
Straßen dann Platz für Graffiti die
Kunst bringt ein wenig Träumerei erlaubt
dem Alltag zu entfliehen ermöglicht auch
ein wenig nachzudenken über den Sinn des
Lebens und die Gesellschaft
das calvinistisch geprägte Genf das
traditionell anders tickt als der Rest
des Landes hat entschieden wir hängen
Werbeplakate ab bis 2025 jahrelang hat
die Bürgerinitiative Geneve Zero Typ
Genf ohne Werbung dafür gekämpft
Liberalismus
will dass wir Bürger konsumieren immer
mehr konsumieren ohne darüber
nachzudenken welche Auswirkungen das hat
auf die Umwelt oder über die sozialen
Auswirkungen und ohne auf die Leute zu
achten die diese Produkte nicht
konsumieren können
dieser Moment hat den Ausschlag gegeben
2017 bleiben die Flächen leer weil
Werbeverträge ausgelaufen sind und
plötzlich ist da eine Spielwiese eine
Alternative
Genf wäre nicht die erste Stadt ohne
Werbung was in Sao Paulo begann sich in
Grenoble fortsetzt wird auch in Berlin
diskutiert das Abhängen hat begonnen
aber da ist doch wieder stand etwa im
Genfer Stadtrat
die grundfirma
die großen internationalen Firmen werden
doch weiter Werbung auf ihren
Plattformen zeigen vor allem die
sogenannten gaffem Google Amazon
Facebook Microsoft sie schaffen keine
Jobs in Genf und wir haben dadurch umso
weniger Steuereinnahmen
wie sehr manipulieren Werbeplakate
überhaupt das Problem sei doch die
personalisierte Werbung im Netz die zum
Betrachten zwingt und nicht Plakate
findet werbepsychologe Engeln Werbung
ist nicht per se etwas Böses sondern
trägt auch in positiven Teilen zu
unserer Kultur bei gerade diese
erweiterten Bedürfnisse nach ja Kultur
nach Lebensgefühl nach Esprit nach
positive Geist und positiver Einstellung
zum Leben die wird sehr stark durch
Kommunikation einfach getragen
wie fast jede Geschichte hat auch diese
ein paar Haken die den Wurf womöglich
kleiner ausfallen lassen ein
Volksentscheid könnte das Genfer
Werbeverbot noch kippen und auf privaten
Flächen bleibt das Verbot so oder so
wirkungslos
und nun müssen wir aufpassen dass
niemand die nächsten anderthalb Minuten
für Werbung hält das wäre total falsch
Laura barnick meldet nur die Termine
nächster Woche auf die wir jetzt
natürlich schon achten das sind die
Pläne und dann passiert das Leben
[Musik]
die SPD will morgen mögliche Vorsitzende
vorstellen Parteichef Norbert Walter
borjans hatte vergangene Woche erklärt
er stünde nicht erneut zur Wahl nun
sucht die SPD eine Neubesetzung für die
2019 eingeführte Doppelspitze Saskia
esken wird erneut antreten
Generalsekretär Lars Klingbeil ist
ebenfalls für den Chefposten im Gespräch
am Dienstag wird der Bundestag feierlich
an den 9 November erinnern er vereint
gleich mehrere bedeutsame Ereignisse der
jüngeren deutschen Geschichte
1918 war mit dem ausrufen der Ersten
Republik das Ende der deutschen
Monarchie besiegelt in mahnender
Erinnerung wird ebenfalls der
Reichspogromnacht 1938 gedacht ein
weiteres historisches Schlaglicht 51
Jahre später der Mauerfall 1989
am Mittwoch wird auf der Herbstsynode
der evangelischen Kirche in Bremen die
Nachfolge des Ratsvorsitzenden Heinrich
Bedford-Strohm entschieden nach Margot
Käßmann könnte mit der Hamburger
Bischöfin Kerstin fährst zum zweiten Mal
eine Frau der evangelischen Kirche
vorstehen
bereits letztes Jahr hatte Andreas
Voßkuhle das Amt des obersten Richters
am Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe
niedergelegt pandemiebedingt wurde der
Festakt zum präsidentenwechsel
verschoben am kommenden Freitag wird
vosskuhlin und feierlich verabschiedet
und sein Nachfolger Stefan habert
offiziell im Amt begrüßt werden
und das Wetter wird in dieser
Novemberwoche überwiegend ruhig immer
mal wird auch die Sonne durchkommen
morgen bleibt es noch teils wechseln
teils stark bewölkt im Norden und Osten
gibt es etwas Regen im Südwesten größere
sonnige Abschnitte bei 6 bis 12 Grad in
den nächsten Tagen ruhiges
Novemberwetter mit einer Mischung aus
Sonne Wolken und viel Nebel nur
vereinzelt etwas Regen 5 bis 13 Grad
wir machen noch aufmerksam auf furia
gleich nach uns seine spielfilmserie
über die internationale des
Rechtsterrorismus militante norwegische
und deutsche radikale planen einen
Anschlag in Berlin den sie Muslimen in
die Schuhe schieben wollen so eine
Bedrohung ist dermaßen nah an der
Realität das Nachrichtenleute auf einen
Spielfilm hinweisen und das wahres von
uns für heute und diese Woche ab morgen
sind wir Slomka und Heinz Wolf hier und
wir zwei wechseln auf ihre Seite als
treue Zuschauer bis bald
[Musik]